hey what is good you [ __ ] sexy mother
efforts uh welcome to another episode of
get close i'm your co-host gio i'm bart
and today we have
family we have [ __ ] joe
jojitsukawa in the [ __ ] podcast
room and i'm so happy to have you dude
did you just say
sexy [ __ ] mother effers did i yeah
cause there's
like you answered one
but not the other
i i don't know i like to limit your
[ __ ] i try to catch people off guard
you know where they go oh she's she's
kind of edgy and then they go oh but she
censored it a little bit so i like to
tease this feels weird it's like it
feels like jk news but not really i know
and that's why i'm happy that you're
here because i haven't been on jk news
for what maybe a year now has it been a
year
maybe even more maybe on and off yeah
and like a part of me feels like my soul
has died a little bit yeah i went from
seeing your face every [ __ ] day
to like
once every two months i know what is
crazy does that make you does that make
you sad do you miss me yeah it's a love
and hate kind of situation you know
let's talk about the love part
i do think the vibe is different though
like i think
if there's something missing because
it's like what it used to be yeah is
changing from what it is like now it's
like
it's like careful boys it's like a boys
group yeah it's like a locker room yeah
uh so then does that mean it's better
without me
a hundred percent
[ __ ]
i'm just [ __ ] fishing for compliments
man i think you should come back yeah
yeah people do miss you though i'm
trying to yeah um but just shit's
[ __ ] i mean i got a kid you know so
they kind of like they kind of need me
all the time family logistics is tough i
remember during the pandemic um we know
whoever was scared so we kept grandma
away we're like you go quarantine and do
your own thing but then she was out like
hanging out with people anyways and then
so
we were like hey it's a selective
quarantine you know right just it's just
funny the way like immigrants do their
own quarantine but um we have a kid so
we both can't go to jk at the same time
yeah so without the help of grandma it's
either one or the other yeah and since
i'm the better castmate i was the one
that jk news dude you're not wrong
you're not wrong like i yeah you're
definitely not the freer one yeah yeah
uh uh no i mean i definitely missed that
energy i missed the vibe i missed
[ __ ] around like i feel so rusty like
i'm here doing a podcast but i i
like he feels like way more fluid and
like his like his [ __ ] i don't know
what are they called like you're just
more oiled up and i just feel like i'm
like
i was like
just having a conversation so like when
you vlog and stuff that's not practice
to you nada like not like in a podcast
sense because you're working with people
yeah and i'm just like talking about
this direct thing that i'm like dealing
with
uh but no i love that you're here
because i want to [ __ ] catch up i
haven't talked to you like you said in a
few months i think the last time i saw
you we were at david's house
um but we didn't really get to talk very
much and even before then was probably
another few months right it was like a
few months and then we saw david's house
in another few months right yeah when
was the last time we saw before that
oh when we had dinner at david's yeah
that was a minute ago oh man yeah
all right so catch me up what the [ __ ]
is going on
so you just came back from hawaii right
yeah okay so i get yeah i'm i'm building
a business out there haven't released
what it is yet because it's gonna be a
surprise okay but in order to do that i
had to establish roots right so then
like i'm you know i i got a place with
our
hawaii family out there nancy and sean
yeah and then um i'm living near uh
in town which is near waikiki and stuff
yeah yeah what's the address
[Laughter]
1544 hakahaka place yes yeah that's
right okay but even before that um like
i i saw so i was kind of in and out uh
from jk for a bit so i had taika
um while i was pregnant i was doing a
lot of the jk news and i remember
[ __ ] falling asleep on set and [ __ ]
cuz i was just like
[ __ ] pregnant as [ __ ] and you can't
have caffeine or you can't have a lot of
it did you ever catch her doing that
yeah
yeah you would you would you'd be like
are you okay and i was like i'm so sorry
because she'll be like when you were
pregnant yeah like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
yeah you guys would be talking and i'm
like listening and i'm just like dozing
off
i thought you were just bored no i'm
just kidding i don't remember that
that's crazy yeah you were like hey are
you okay and i'm like yeah man my bad
like i'm just [ __ ] i'm dying over
here okay and then slowly when once
tycho was born um i i was removing
myself from a lot of things that i just
was taking up too much of my time
jk was being one of them and i was like
no hey jake hey but yeah i had to do
what i had to do
um and then in that time a bunch of our
lives changed significantly yeah yours
was one of the journeys that i was like
blown away by because you went from like
working like crazy for [ __ ] a decade
or longer from since i've known you yeah
uh to then going wait
i need some [ __ ] me time oh and then
you just started traveling the world all
right so this was 2019 yeah before
covid right yeah i think it's because
well
it probably started from the breakup
between me and jess
and then like
being single again and then like
reevaluating life because like when
you're building
life with someone
then your goals are kind of like okay so
where do we nest or where do we build
right right but then it's like a reset
button when you become single again
because it's like oh [ __ ] so
now i have to rebuild myself
in my own like journey again yeah so
it's like you could be going
somewhere with someone when you have
like a life partner you're like all
right so what are you what are your
goals you want to do this what are your
hobbies right and then like let's see
how we can
kind of fit in in that way yeah and then
when that's wiped out then it's like
almost like
going back before you got into that
relationship right and then like doing
all the things that you wanted to do
that maybe because of time because of
responsibilities you couldn't yeah and i
got to go through this crazy bucket list
of stuff like what what was it okay so i
want to live through you man first thing
was traveling okay because you remember
the first thing i did was go to vietnam
yes because for the longest time our old
buddy danny doe
he um he was the first og [ __ ] jk
director yeah yeah and he kept saying
you guys got to come to vietnam
and so i was like these people say that
that's true so i was like i don't trust
you dude you're trying to lure me into a
trap i feel like every person says you
got to come to my country except for
like indian people they'll be like why
do you want to go ahead
don't go to india you're so right dude
i've heard that they're like don't go to
india yeah and everyone else is like oh
you got to see japan or like you got to
see this and then they like can't wait
to brag about the country yeah but
anyways like yeah so i was like you know
what
let's go let's go like i'm just gonna go
from that point on i was like all right
where else haven't i gone i haven't gone
to europe i haven't gone this place
whatever
and it was just this
crazy journey of like
feeling like i can do whatever i want
i'm just gonna do it yeah you feel like
you
uh made up for lost time quote unquote
you know because you're building your
your life with someone and then when you
have to start backwards i feel like
there's got to be some sort of like oh
man like what a cut of [ __ ] or whatever
but then now you're able to kind of live
your own life do you feel like you're
able to make up for all the lost time
and all the stuff that you have to put
on the back burner yeah did it even feel
like lost time oh because it might have
not even felt that way
i don't know if it was lost time or if
that's the right words yeah it felt more
like um
doing all the things that i wanted to do
as a child
that i forgot that i loved like more
snowboarding yeah right yeah more like
uh more traveling to places that like
you don't have to worry about because
you're not in a big group or you're not
even with you're just alone yeah so then
going from being in a couple where
you're like living with someone and
you're sharing everything yeah doing
everything being completely alone it's
like a huge transition because it's like
i think from there you got to find
yourself again
and then from that point it was like
because we know you guys have been
together for so long 13 years dude yeah
but your identities are tied because you
guys work together in so many ways right
so everything is like blended six years
man that's how you do math
it just doubles like it was it's a long
time
yeah
yeah no i just threw it i just threw in
a [ __ ] i know it's 26 but i just
wanted to make it extra crazy i forgot i
was in a room [ __ ] full of asians
that know how to fast math all right i
just was [ __ ] around can't be [ __ ]
around dude that's like me in a room
full of mexicans i gotta keep everything
locked up
anyway
but yeah like you know you know when
you're in a relationship you mold
together and then like you kind of
that's your other person right so then
like
you make sacrifices but you also add new
things because this person but then when
you go back to being completely alone
and you don't have to watch out for
anybody else but yourself
there's a lot of free time because of
that gap is gone yeah so then with that
now it's like how do you fill up that
time
because then it's like if you were
working together or doing whatever stuff
and now that's gone it's like
wait
there's things that i wanted to do that
maybe i couldn't have done or there's
things that i always wanted to explore
but i didn't have the time to yeah and
those were the things that were like
really interesting because i was like oh
[ __ ] so this is what a divorcee feels
like yeah well that sounds fun to be a
divorcee hey hey hey slow your role i
talked to joe after joe what are you
doing man what are you doing what's
going on it's great
i'm missing out um but that's tight that
you chose yourself quote unquote you
chose yourself um because you could have
easily just dove into work again you
could have easily just started building
some new [ __ ] you know and just been
like that boat kind of sailed like what
was the spark or the flip that you're
like nah [ __ ] that i'm gonna have fun
i think i felt deprived of fun so like
we were having a lot of fun and what we
did like
i'm not gonna lie like it was you know
that journey that with the building
phase yeah that was great and then the
money was even greater
but then it got bad because it got to
the point where um i remember all of us
felt guilty for not working yeah and we
all faced burnout because we would see
each other work and then i'm like well
am i being lazy i'm not i got to pick up
my slack because i don't want to leave
you hanging or you hanging and i see
everyone going hard
but it was like a toxic kind of hustle
culture right yeah because i think one
none of us wanted to feel like we were
letting each other down yeah and none of
us wanted to feel too lazy and then the
other part was like
i felt ungrateful
if i refused the type of money we were
getting yeah so like we would lose sleep
because we're like we never had these
opportunities before because we went
from
basically not even making a dime yeah to
to doing overnight shows for gas money
remember we went to san francisco like
so we wouldn't like
what was it like we we
we couldn't quit like we couldn't we
couldn't not go to work because we still
needed to have our jobs right yeah but
we did an overnight trip so we could
still do a show and gain followers and
it didn't pay anything but like maybe
gas money and food yeah it was the same
day trip yeah i remember we we left
and then we drove to san francisco we
did the show and since oh you had work
immediately in the morning uh and i
think i had to tutor the next day geo
drove back and he slept in the car right
i remember that was crazy and then we
went straight to work the next morning
yeah yeah yeah and then so like coming
from a place like that where like dude
we made like a hundred dollars for a
show or something right yeah we probably
lost like [ __ ] [ __ ] like 300 right
but just getting there those were some
of my greatest memories yeah and then it
went from having six figure deals or
whatever and then when we were getting
these offers it was hard to say no
because i didn't know when the next time
we would have another deal like that
yeah because people say like
entertainment is like it's fleeting yeah
it's like [ __ ] dude i don't know if
tomorrow no one likes us anymore yeah
it's like but we're lucky because we're
the cockroaches of youtube
we can survive any apocalypse now i'm
stick around yeah we have some of the
most loyal die hard
awesome fan base that just stick with us
like over a decade now right but when we
first started
that was like i think that's what it was
and then so like
years went by of us just like never
saying no to sponsorships or whatever it
was and opportunities we just kept
growing and growing and growing
and then i think it came to the point
where like we also grew up broke
not being able to afford things so like
we we fell into a little bit of that
consumerism right where we were just
buying things and like for whatever
reason like there was one year we bought
more guns then we went to go shoot and
enjoy them yeah
we just went to the gun store like every
month yeah because the california has
the 10 day wait period and you can't buy
more than one pistol so we just made it
like a routine thing every month we're
just gonna collect one because the most
pistols you could buy is 12. you go once
a month but you need way more i mean
guns do dudes is like shoes to girls you
know yeah you guys are getting watches
yeah it was just luxury cars right
but that's kind of like
i think because we were deprived for
like years where a lot of our friends
were slowly buying [ __ ] and then they
would have
you know their joy like little by little
yeah and then we held off for like seven
years straight being broke as hell yeah
and then it went just like i'm gonna do
whatever i want because it went from
corolla to two luxury cars right
so it's like it's not it's not like
corolla and then maybe like um lexus or
something lexus yeah and then maybe you
go up and and and get something better
like a mercedes or like a you know
whatever there's like two exotics right
away yeah and then so
that was also what i think contributed
to it i'm glad i got it out of my system
because everyone has to experience it
too yeah yep like because it's also
confidence building to achieve and go
like oh i wanted that and i was able to
get it yes yeah and then you could go
back and say i want to be a minimalist
or i don't you know i don't have to get
everything every single time that's
what's so funny is like we've had like
crazy cars but the car that makes me the
happiest right now just my pickup truck
down there dude same here i have a
pickup truck and then i got one with
bench seats like a fit six people it's
the best every day i take tycho to
school he gets to sit in the front with
me and he's so [ __ ] happy i love it
dude it's awesome and it's like half the
price yeah of what your luxury car
there's i'm surprised it has [ __ ]
power windows like that's how basic it
is that's how basic it is
cloth seats and this is six but i get to
do all kinds of fun stuff with it it's
awesome yeah i feel like now the way we
like get things is like
there's more thought be behind like
like customizing or like it's really for
you versus like when we first got into
this it was like
i'm just gonna get everything because i
can yeah
but i think that
that part we saw the dark side of it
like everyone tells you about it right
but i feel like we're the type of people
that needs to do it and experience it
firsthand
to go
that's the reason why people say this is
this is never ending yeah right
it's like an addiction and then whatever
and then so i think um
i got to the point of burnout where we
realized oh [ __ ] like
it's it's been too long too much and
then like i didn't really get to do the
[ __ ] that i wanted to do because i
remember a time where um
it's crazy where it's like we could be
stockpiled on skits or we're stockpiled
on work so we're technically ahead yeah
and then an opportunity would come up to
go shoot or snowboard or something but
it's like on a weekday or something and
i would feel guilty so i would just say
no
but then it's like that's supposed to be
one of the benefits of an entrepreneur
where you set your own schedule but we
had an office everyone showed up so i
would be like no i'm not going to go
and then i'm like
but because i felt guilty about it you
know and then i ended up on the weekend
then i feel like i'm supposed to do the
side hustle [ __ ] which is our vlogs or
whatever so it ends up being you just
never do anything you like for a long
time yeah and no matter what like it's
the things that we do is fun and i think
that's also
a hard way to remove yourself because
it's so fun that when you do it you
forget that it's work too yeah and then
like there's no work-life balance
because
you know it's like the it's it's
difficult but then when you get into the
groove
it's just you're in it so you forget
that it's like burning you out yeah but
it's a dove it was a it's a different
difficult because like you said it was
fun and it didn't feel like work but it
is work so we all took it very seriously
but because we all
uh were friends or our friends um it was
like cool like at least we're grinding
it out together like i got to see you i
got to be with you like i had my friends
around me so i'm like dude i'm building
and making money let's [ __ ] go
and if you think about it this is what i
think it's our 15th year
shut up yeah like we're a whole high
school student oh [ __ ] on on on youtube
you're right so
if you like a lot of people don't last
this long on youtube yeah you know and
and it makes sense because like the [ __ ]
that we had to go through but if we
didn't have each other do you think we
would have lasted this long probably not
yeah probably not yeah because we made
it pleasant like we know friends who are
solo youtubers that are just like so
done yeah in a couple of years yeah
and they're so depressed and then they
they they get the money but then they
realize like you were saying like the
money isn't really anything because it's
like you can buy whatever you want and
after you get it you're like well that
happiness is kind of fleeting now what
like i'm still alone i'm still grinding
like i don't have the work life balance
yeah i get it i remember there was one
year where um
we were going to vacation so we can
sleep
remember oh yeah we would get airbnbs in
in hawaii yeah and we would go there and
most of the time was spent with us and
david sleeping in the house passing out
everywhere and relaxing and i was like
why are we here like we could do this at
home yeah we should be at the beach and
then we just had no more energy we're
just sleeping at the beach yeah we did a
beach to sleep we'd even swim
and i think all those things kind of
added up and then during the pandemic it
gave me time to really think and be
alone and be and reevaluate everything
and then so i was like i don't want to
feel obligated to this because it should
be fun like when we do
everything right we should be walking
into it like i can't freaking wait to
talk to you guys in on jk news or all
these things but i started feeling like
oh i have to do it
and i think that's when it kind of
scared me because i never felt like i
had to do it oh wow yeah so it's like i
have to vlog or i have to do this and
that's when it changed my relationship
with creativity yeah because when you're
just meeting a quota
your quality starts sucking
and then you're just robotic and you're
not changing you're not evolving and
then so i was like maybe it's just
better for me to hey i make enough like
let me just enjoy life again
and then when i vlog when i do stuff
with my friends when i create content on
jk news
it's more from a place of authenticity
like i'm here to
enjoy myself and then i think when you
enjoy yourself the fans do you know i
think they sense it they sense when
we're forcing the content and like we're
just it's just we're not on our a-game
that day i think they feel all of that
and i was like if i keep doing this and
i'm burning out
they're probably going to be bored of
the content too yeah that's true yeah do
you
do you journal because these are like
some pretty deep
introspective thoughts like do you
journal or do you just or do you talk to
yourself i talk to myself how long
uh maybe but like you're not being
authentic you know that oh [ __ ] that's
so true
i thought i talked to myself and i
talked to people
who
are in the same boat so like me and
david will have this conversation and we
were like oh dude like
i think we've experienced burnout for
two years straight yeah and then i think
we're all just such good hard workers we
don't even know
you know like yeah we're [ __ ] muted
we could be burnt out yeah and like
we just keep going and we don't even
know until we're burnt out until like
[ __ ] two years later yeah well even
burnout is a new concept for me like our
parents never talk or my parents never
talked to me about burnout like they
were always working
yeah like we didn't really take
vacations and if we took a vacation it
was like whoa what the [ __ ] and it was
like a road trip somewhere and they're
probably passing out
yeah but i was just like oh that's just
what adults do you just [ __ ] work
like yeah they don't retire too if you
think about it our parents all of our
parents just want to keep going yeah and
my mom didn't retire until like late 60s
oh [ __ ] so like yeah but she actually
enjoyed her job and she likes routine
and she likes
income because she gets to go on
vacations so like
but yeah you're right i don't think
burnout was in in anyone's yeah i never
thought about that like it was it's such
a new concept for me where i'm like
[ __ ] what do i feel so heavy inside and
it's like oh [ __ ] maybe you're
experiencing burnout and i'm like what
do you think that's a good concept [ __ ]
do you think that's a crutch then you
think that's like a
something bad to know where it's like if
you didn't know then it's almost like
ignorance
is bliss and you just keep going
uh yes and no uh i would say no because
it's not good because
it's gonna it seeps out in everything
right like it seems like our
relationships it's gonna seep out in
whatever it is that you're trying to to
do you're going to hate whatever it is
that you were passionate about before so
i think that's really unhealthy um but i
think dwelling on it and then looking
for like is it burnout all the time like
oh maybe i'm burned out and then using
that as a crutch i think it's bad you
try something for two days am i burnt
out you know yeah like i i think true i
think really being honest with yourself
and being like
um
am am i feeling burnt out or am i just
struggling and being challenged by this
one thing i think that's where it's
healthy in my personal
perspective yeah i think i think um like
from everything that i did like from
trying to work out or just any new thing
that i attempt i i obsess so much that
everything became 100 every day but then
like
you know that's impossible you can't 100
youtube every day you can't 100
there's gonna be a point where
life happens right or other things need
attention or like you need to rest and i
think that philosophy is true for
everything you do but
my personality was
of the type where i just addictively
obsessively immerse myself into
something so hard that like now i'm
scaling back like a little bit every day
is actually way better like that one uh
russian fitness dude on joe rogan was
talking about how the russian method of
working out is like
a little every day and at the end of the
year you do way more than the guy that
went ham yeah only multiple times a week
because he has to rest yeah so i was
like oh that makes a lot of sense baby
steps right but i get too excited and i
don't know how to babysit but now since
i'm balancing like that i feel like life
is much more
relaxed accomplished but then like not
so intense
yeah
so then it was a series of like life
experiences and events that you're like
oh [ __ ] i need to scale back a bit i
need to take care of myself
um and it is a lot of deep introspective
thought and [ __ ] where like were there
like books that you were reading that
you're just like aha
yeah i think i'm really into
any way
like getting information that can push
me further into figuring things out so
like
if i'm emotionally in pain or physically
in pain or if i want to achieve a goal
or whatever like i feel like we're
living in a generation where all of that
info we have access to
and it's really good because like you
have
actual geniuses
that invented the thing to teach you you
have successful business people who
who's done it themselves like back in
the day right like we were part of the
generation where
like you had to go to the library for
info you had to go to school you had to
be an apprentice and you got to read
like sun tzu or some [ __ ]
like gotta decipher this [ __ ]
yeah bro remember [ __ ] uh what is the
[ __ ] maps that big thick uh the maps
instead of us having the phone or
computer yeah like thomas guide yeah
remember that [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're old so
yeah i think just like us being on
youtube right and then like
i feel that
you're back then it was like your
village is the only access you had right
so education was a big deal like to go
to college because you had the best and
brightest in one physical location but
now with our phone we can basically
access genius and then so that's true
there's a genius for everything like
emotional intelligence or physical or
whatever right so if i feel like man i
want to figure this out because my
parents are too dumb to teach me this
which is true right
bro i feel like
it's so true what they say like
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
right like you're gonna be like your
parents if that's the only influence you
have
and then so
since i'm not satisfied with the
guidance and whatever with of of people
maybe within my small group i have to
seek further and then i i think that
becomes addicting because then like when
you can
build a skill or new idea or something
that you've been searching for and then
you get taught that you just feel like i
upgraded myself in a video game oh yeah
that's so true this podcast is sponsored
by
better help
has there been something that's been on
your mind or that has been bothering you
as of late i know a lot of people at
least in my friend's circle even me to
be honest um these past couple of years
have been pretty gnarly to say the least
they've been
the most challenging years that i've
ever had and although i have friends and
family that i ultimately trust and adore
and admire
um i always feel like
i can't
completely open up to them
and share all of my struggles or my woes
or just any challenges that i'm facing
because i feel like
for the most part all of these
challenges are very unique to me so
when i found out about betterhelp i was
really excited because you get matched
up with a licensed therapist as quickly
as 48 hours and what i love about it
even more is that you get to do it from
the comfort of your own home at your own
time you send an email you know you talk
about whatever it is that it's on your
mind it doesn't have to be
you don't have to feel like you're going
crazy but it also helps if you feel like
you're going crazy to send that message
and be like hey you know what i'm kind
of struggling with these things i'm
having these thoughts i'm having these
you know things happen in my life and
what do you think about it and when you
talk to a licensed therapist
it's really comforting because they're
not there to solve the problems for you
they're there to help you work through
the problems together they're to guide
you they're going to help you by asking
all the right questions that maybe your
close friends and family who are very
smart might not be qualified to do or
help you in that area so i'm so excited
to be sharing better help with you guys
um because like i said you're going to
be matched with the licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you get to do from the
comfort of your own home and if you want
it to to feel more um
i don't know like a personal
um uh feeling then you can have like
video conference you can you can talk on
the phone you don't have to feel alone
and you don't have to go through life
feeling as if no one understands what
you're going through um so for everyone
listening right now we're going to hook
you guys up with 10 off your first month
all you have to do is go to
betterhelp.com
get close you're going to get 10 off
your first month
try it out trust me you're gonna love it
i love that you've always used that line
ever since i've known you you've always
called life a video game and you're like
that's what makes life fun for me yeah
it is literally and especially if you
played games like gta and whatever it's
like so blending with reality like oh
yeah i actually learned fashion from
video games okay yeah walk me through
all that because i don't play games well
you actually did help me with basics
when we went shopping and stuff like
that nice okay but then
i actually during that time though i see
like i i'm very practical in a way where
like i don't like to buy things just
because it makes me feel good um i want
to make a lot of money first and then i
have a budget that's like okay that's
going to help me i can use that and
explore like me too like if i was an
artist i'm like
uh i don't want to buy all of the colors
so i'm just going to use
black and get really good with this
because it's too expensive and then i'm
going to sell this piece and then i'm
going to buy the colors damn true
yeah more entrepreneurial i guess in my
mindset
so i have to earn the color set and
upgrade that way wow yeah so then when
it came to clothes and stuff like that
like
yeah i could go thrift and all this but
it was like man i don't know where to
start
so in the video games you can buy
clothes like you could dress your
character up and then i would just
accessorize and do all that stuff and
i'm like damn this is fun how cute how
much time did you spend on [ __ ]
dressing your character up
oh my god
you can like get rings and you can go to
the mall you can buy some new stuff it's
like you go rob a liquor store you like
beat some people up you save up all this
money the good old days yeah and then
you go into the you go into the mall and
then you buy a suit or you buy you know
workout clothes or whatever and i was
like dude this is okay this is how you
match colors and stuff yeah it's [ __ ]
cute uh so that's all that's where you
got a lot of like your um
uh uh what is it like the parallels of
like real life being like a [ __ ]
video game but i still don't understand
wow like um i understand the fashion
part of it right but like how do you
view it as a video game right because in
a video game there's no real
consequences
oh yeah i guess there's but in life
there's a bunch of consequences like you
can lose
people you can lose fortune you can lose
businesses you can it's it's [ __ ]
real life dude there's real life
consequences that's true i do think that
i just break it for you
i have a big risk tolerance in in terms
of like
what i feel is a consequence so like
what are consequences for you
death that's it i guess well i i live on
very little right so like if you're i
always say that if your standards of
happiness is like this low
and the world is here then you're always
very satisfied
so and and i think satisfied is
different from
like content or like or like unmotivated
or whatever right or complacent yeah
like i always like to grow and build and
i think that's the the journey is the
fun part because what makes life
good
to i mean like what makes life like
fulfilling is the purpose
because um
oh before i get into that like one thing
i learned about in the journey that i
did were just i was just playing for the
whole year
is that i realized that you can only do
so much of fun
and then it gets boring
because like
during the pandemic right when you say
playing do you mean in the video game or
in real life oh real life
yeah like
so like i decided that i'm gonna put
adventure fun and all this stuff do
whatever i want first and foremost right
like i was retired the pandemic i felt
like i was retired because i was like
barely working and then i
snowboarded like all over america i
that's so yeah
i was like in utah i was like in the
east coast
if a friend calls me up and it's like
let's just go surfing let's do it let's
go skating let's do it let's go mountain
biking whatever i put fun first
and then
several months later
there's something missing there's like
wait i gotta do something like i wanna
build and i thought i was burnt out to
the point where i'm done with business i
don't wanna do anything
but i realized that i just needed a
break
because when i started you know working
on the mushroom farm and doing all these
other projects i was like i actually
love business and i love building and
i'm not tired
of this whole thing
and then so purpose i think
is a good
motivator because you need a you need a
goal and you need to like work towards
something
and it can't just be working toward a
hobby and a skill i think you have to be
or at least for me i have to be rewarded
where i'm like giving something to
society and people are paying for it and
then they like it or whatever yeah yeah
what's that japanese thing um
or something oh it's ikigai so it's like
a balance of like
like all of your like your career right
your yeah hobby whatever yeah and that's
kind of similar to what you're saying
right
yeah i think
i'm kind of like
figuring out all the balance that i need
to feel fulfilled and to feel like whole
yeah have you you feel like you've
reached that right now
yeah i feel like i got a better
understanding of balance because like
one was like working too much
and then like
yeah and then and then you lose the
purpose and you lose the meaning
because then it becomes robotic and it's
too much of it you need to take a step
back and be like wait why was i doing it
in the first place
and then you have too much fun and then
it's just like
you can only enjoy so much to the point
where like it gets boring like like
like drinking too much gets boring and
it becomes an addiction like [ __ ] too
much gets boring after a while or like
everything right i like that you've
taken everything to the [ __ ] highest
notches and you're like yeah drinking
too much is too boring [ __ ] too much
oh god don't even get me started i'm
like really joking yeah what is that
like that's dope though i think it's
always good to find like your your like
what are they called like the side rails
yeah and then so that way you could like
you slam hard to the left yeah harden to
the right and then you figure out like
where the middle is yeah that's usually
where like the happiness is or not even
just that line but then
balance going left and right i think is
cons you constantly experience a little
bit of both you know
what is it the richter scale where it
just kind of goes like this like it
moves yeah it's never going to be like a
straight line yeah at least that's how i
view i don't i don't view like happiness
as a line i feel i feel like happiness
is actually achieved through a little
bit of controlled sadness and a little
bit of like controlled mania yeah
and then that is what is actually like
like a progressive happiness yeah i
think that's what i started to realize
is like just a little bit of everything
is
is challenging and fun but when it goes
to the point of too much
then it's
that's when the burnout happens we're
like let's say like i'm trying to learn
how to swim right then maybe
10 hours of one day yeah like it's too
much or like you get thrown into the
deep end
and you're around sharks it's too much
right it's like the stress meter so like
a little bit of whatever is entertaining
and it's and it's good and then you can
practice but then when it's too much too
fast then it's like
it's too crazy yeah yeah
but that yeah i think that that balance
is what i learned it was like oh [ __ ]
yeah duh everyone says this but like
like i said i'm i'm the dumb stubborn
type where i have to do it and you're
never full of those people i know right
that's us too like we we just have to we
have to say [ __ ] it and we we [ __ ] go
to the extreme and we're like oh right
yeah that's we should have listened to
people but we don't because we just have
to experience it ourselves yeah and
sometimes you experience things yourself
and then the lesson that you learn is
worded in the right way
you know because sometimes you hear it
or you read it and you kind of
understand the concept but you don't
feel it until you do it and then you
reword the word like the saying and
you're like oh [ __ ] okay i know what
they're talking about now right right
and it depends on the person that's
delivering the message too because then
you might be like oh no you're kind of a
[ __ ] or i don't know you're kind of
crazy so really does depend on that
yeah what were you saying i forgot the
other question that you had
um could you uh because you i was saying
that you uh you've always compared life
to a video game oh yeah yeah so that's
really what has helped you at least like
i don't know do what what am i pursuing
what are my risks right you never viewed
it like that as a game yeah
um i don't think i played enough games
to like draw that parallel i never
played that many games i sucked ass at
all of them yeah but since day one
i realized life is a good video game
explain it to me then so you mean like
even like a basic um super mario right
you're going dude
this guy goes boom hits a mushroom he
eats mushrooms twice as strong right or
on level two you get that flower and
also you can shoot fireballs
so what does that tell you so like you
go you're like okay cool you see like
the kid across the street that also
knows how to ollie really good you're
like he's just a better human being than
i am you know or you go see the other
kid and that kid's like playing
basketball better like wait we both have
these meat vessels
but his machine like you just i just
start to see like oh man i think i got a
kia and that guy got like a [ __ ] ford
raptor body and like and you know and
then just as people start progressing
and acquiring skills and whatever i'm
like oh wait this guy's a [ __ ] hummer
this is way different than mine mine i
need an oil change like you know and
then slowly just through life as people
both physically mentally intellectually
as they add more and more skills i just
see their character being like this most
bulletproof character to the point where
i think like where they exaggerate in
fantasy you become neo right like neo is
so above everyone now he just fly
everywhere yeah but you see like the the
input of skills and you see how neo that
knows kung fu versus the neo that
doesn't know kung fu is already a huge
difference yeah no i never saw it like
that what do you see it as
um you didn't see like oh wait that
person knows guitar this person doesn't
know guitar this person is already one
level above this guy uh yeah i would see
that but i was like well i know how they
got that right because you practice but
they have it
like it's yeah i think the way you're
seeing it is you logically know how they
have it but they have it yeah it's like
me being in the room with the black belt
i'm like okay yeah he trained his ass
off for 10 15 years yeah yeah but the
other way i view it is at any he's
letting me live right now yeah yeah
that's the real truth is when i'm in the
room with this guy he's letting me live
at any time he doesn't want me to live
it's up to him it's not up to me i don't
have the keys to this car
yeah
it's a video game in a sense where
everything is an acquired skill so like
i think that there's different schools
of thought right like so of approaching
life like some people
i think that they just exist
and they think that everything is like
lucky or you're born that way what's
happening to them it's happening to them
so
i feel like they they react to life and
i i think the ones that believe that
it's more like a video game they know
that they're the character that can
acquire skills
so for me everything is a learned skill
like like being a better husband or
boyfriend or like being a better
practitioner of martial arts or being a
better business person sure there might
be some natural
i don't know traits that you might have
that works in it like if you're tall you
might be way better at basketball
because it's like yeah or you know
whatever it is right
so you might have these things that are
like
helpful
if you like to try something
but i don't doubt that anybody could
just put time and focus towards
something and then like become something
and i think and i think that
a lot of people who don't understand or
believe that
um
they're still stuck trying to battle
like
like their own fears right because you
have to get over like like let's say you
want to be a painter but you have to get
over having low confidence and is anyone
gonna even like your art and all these
things and then so i realized that my
mind doesn't go there first but by
talking to students and talking to
people i realize that the most of people
they have to deal with all of these
issues of worry and like how someone's
talking [ __ ] or whatever
and and that just like analysis
paralysis right where they can't even
become better and i was like oh [ __ ] so
so
treating everything like a video game
it's like when you play a game the
character never asks
am i gonna get better like mario doesn't
like
become depressed you know what i mean
like imagine
he's just out there to collect his coins
to level up and just to do the thing and
then so
yeah i guess that's that's how i view
life is just oh i like snowboarding now
let me watch the videos or like
you know i can't
focus let me watch a video on how to
focus and then acquire the skills yeah
you said um
with your conversations and encounters
with people when you're talking about
like i guess pursuing a passion or like
trying to acquire a new skill set you've
realized that they
kind of stop they get in their own way
yeah and you're saying you said that you
don't do that where does your head go
first
i want it really bad and that's it yeah
like it always was that way and um it
was funny too because just last night i
was talking to my cousin
and and um
he was he was saying how like we were
talking about how guys today might not
be as assertive as like before they're
just [ __ ] yeah guys are [ __ ] soft
now because there's [ __ ] toxic
masculinity so they're prevented they're
like don't do that right yeah because
assertiveness is it's like you have to
practice to understand what that is you
can't just be overtly aggressive that
that's just hiding your
security yeah because that's not
confidence either
yeah and then you
you can't yeah so so you can't be just a
blunt [ __ ] either you gotta you know
but anyways so like we were talking
about that he was hey you you know you
since you're a baby you've always been
that way and i'm like really like i
didn't have to learn it
and then i'm like maybe i'm impulsive
and then my girlfriend was like no i
think um what was the word she used it
wasn't impulsive she says you just know
what you want
and then you ask for it like decisive or
i think so it was like something along
those where it's totally slipped mommy
oh some british weird
proper yeah
your teas and
crumpets that's what you are
so you've always been that way they said
that's ty yeah so i feel really lucky
because i've always said that like a lot
of the things that
people feel insecure about um it doesn't
happen to me until after the fact
what do you mean so like
for example right like with youtube and
things like dressing up like a
woman yeah y'all haven't worn some
[ __ ] [ __ ] man i should have been
embarrassed but [ __ ] it you you guys
wore so much of my [ __ ] clothing my
bikinis my high heels my [ __ ] bras
everything
i think that was me finding balance too
playing with my bras well i think like
growing up late 90s early 2000s right we
live in like super gang macho time so i
remember like just fronting like chin up
chest out all the time people get into
fights all the time you get hit up and
it was just such a like
macho um that's the true toxic yeah
that true like yeah that toxic masculine
environment
that i think you know we talked about
before we're like secretly like i would
watch people get be the scarecrow and
wizard of oz and i'm like oh i want to
do that yeah you wanted to sing and you
wanted my place friends to [ __ ] make
fun of me or get my ass whatever so i
didn't want to do any of that stuff
and then i think you're just overly
macho which isn't you because you no one
is 24 7 macho and i think once we
started doing jk
it was so easy for me to just boom hit
the other side because it i was just
like [ __ ] this the entire other side
that i was missing i've already done all
that stuff and that didn't make me happy
you know i had like felt feel like i was
fronting all the whole time and then so
we went the other way around and it was
actually really liberating being an
asian mom yeah being an asian mom
having your ballsacks show from the
bottom of your shorts yeah it was
actually very liberating
just having fun really like not being so
tense and like covering up who you are
yeah it takes so much work right and i
think that's just real confidence it's
like
being unapologetically who you are it
sounds so cliche but that's who you
gotta be it's like
yeah um but i think even with all of
that i've always been more
okay so when i want something that's all
i could think about
and and then like
i i think like
what i realized is that there's people
who go
what if i fail
and then i get fomo of what if i never
get to try it and then i die
that like i need to try this because
it's scarier to me
because it's guaranteed that if i don't
do it i fail because i never tried it
yeah man you sound like all the [ __ ]
memes that are getting passed around in
ig
i know right yeah that's that's it's
true
very much is true that's why they're
getting passed around because how many
people do you know you talk to them
right and they tell you like hey what's
like one thing like if i could snap your
finger if i snap my finger down like a
genie what's one skill or one thing you
would do everyone has something yeah
yeah and then you go why don't you do it
you're like oh i know right and then
you're like well it's actually pretty
easy you just sign up and we start doing
it like once or twice a week but i know
but there's just something in their own
way that they they like never do it yeah
some of it's failure yeah some people is
just they have all these other
uh speculative like negative
repercussions i'm gonna get hurt or what
if i do this or what if my people look
at me this way and there's just so many
imaginary obstacles that aren't even the
case yeah i do have those thoughts but
like i said it's usually after the fact
so like it's not before i do it because
ignorance is bliss right
and then
let's say like so for example um
snowboarding right like people would go
oh it looks risky dangerous i don't know
right and then it's not till i fall on
my tailbone and i'm like oh i shouldn't
have done this i almost crapped my pants
right
true story
really and then like
later
i get better and i get some close calls
and i'm like oh [ __ ] what if i actually
died back there
so then it's not till way later i start
to process the fear and things like that
like the other day i bought a moped in
hawaii and then like out there they
don't lane split like california so um i
just used to going in between cars right
and then this guy honked the [ __ ] out of
my back and i was like oh [ __ ] and i'm
like that was dangerous sir i was
thinking in my head like
what if i freaking freaked out and then
just you know did something stupid yeah
you're so kind to yourself the [ __ ]
respect
sir let's watch out for ourselves
don't scare me again sire
i do apologize
so i think the holy [ __ ] moment comes
either during or like after like i feel
like even with our youtube career right
like there was no doubt in my mind i was
like hurry up quit that [ __ ] doctor
[ __ ] we're gonna do this [ __ ] right yeah
but it wasn't till after the fact where
we're like how much is this going to
make i know afterwards when you zoom out
you're like damn we were like this close
to being homeless at any given year yeah
yeah
and then it's not really but not really
yeah
but i i feel like i lived in fear
um as we were making the money and i'm
like how long is this gonna last how
long is this going to last
it's really not till i get there
then i start freaking out so like yeah
even i think even in um investing or
crypto or like all these things right
i'll
i've had a swing where like i went from
like a million to like seeing that same
account go to ten thousand dollars
and then most people were like i would
commit suicide and i'm like
yeah did you start off with a million
and then it went that way because that
way i would no no no i probably lost
like a quarter mil but then that thing
went back up but still seeing those
zeroes go down as far as
a quarter mil yeah that's [ __ ] a
house dude from a quarter mile to like
800 000 down to like 10 000. oh my god
right and then yeah it did mess with my
mind because not only that like the way
i couldn't afford to pay my taxes
i was in debt for like 150 000 oh my god
dude yeah but i freaked out like for a
day and i talked to people
and then people that were in worse
situations that got bankrupt for
millions and all that and then like i
didn't feel so bad after all you know
like
when you it's it's kind of like your
asian parent telling you like i used to
walk 10 miles to school this ain't [ __ ]
and then you go
you know what that's true so how did you
deal with it because you just deal with
it and then i started thinking about
like okay
what are the good things that happened
and then i try to hold on to that and
then it's really about um
shifting your baseline so like i'm like
i never had this million when i was 12
years old
i was way happier then i didn't give a
[ __ ] so what what do i need like all
these things are imaginary yeah i just
need to feel safe
i just need a comfortable place to sleep
oh i just need and you're comfortable as
questionable man because you could
[ __ ] sleep on a [ __ ] tree because
that means it's easier to achieve his
happiness it is yeah and then i think i
had to realize that okay so everything
is a game like money the concept of
money is a game like
it's just numbers yeah like it is real
like we can buy things with it and we
can buy like uh you know our health and
safety and you know all this stuff but
at the same time
we can always make more so then you got
to see it as tokens exactly yeah and it
just comes and goes yeah so then
i stopped emotion or trying to
emotionally attach myself to these
things because it's all perspective if
you think of it as i lost
then you feel like
pain because you're like oh i lost that
money well it was never yours yeah it
was like it was never yours to begin
with you borrowed like money is just i
don't know like we don't die with it
right so then all of these things i have
to
question and think about
because ultimately i'm trying to relieve
pain
so like yeah that's that's why i think
yeah that's pretty deep though that's
[ __ ] deep
yeah i do like surrounding myself with
like more extreme people
because they're my measuring tape yeah
you know like when like let's say you go
out in the cold right oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] cold and then someone's like nah
this isn't cold then i try to like okay
yeah you're right it's not cold
it's not cool it's not cold and i try to
like the more people i i meet the longer
my measuring tape gets and then my
emotions it you like let's say if it's
like
plus one inch and minus one inch my
emotions would go crazy but when you
meet people where they're measuring tape
is like a yard on each side yeah then
i'm like why am i giving my level 10
anger to something that's only an inch
versus let me give my level 10 anger to
something that's a yard yeah where if
like my my like let's say if my best
friend [ __ ] my mom maybe then i should
get that mad right i don't want to [ __ ]
your mom by the way
but like why is it like why am i getting
this mad when someone cut me off on the
freeway yeah yeah and i like so when i
meet more extreme people like my
measuring stick gets longer and i adjust
my emotions like oh that looks more
reasonable
yeah i think that's probably why i try
to like search so much for answers
because i don't like
that feeling
of um
roller coaster over little [ __ ]
yeah over anything yeah like you know
just not being able to control how i
feel obsessing over things or like
dwelling upon painful things and that
like it's like a nightmare in my own
mind and i'm like how do i
not do this again because there's people
that figured it out like monks and
whatever so i'm like
how do i exist in life
not avoiding pain but accepting and then
like my threshold gets better each time
yeah because that's a skill in itself
like you mentioned about being cold i
remember like when we had these
discussions do you like summer or winter
i was always on the summer team because
i was like [ __ ] that i hate the cold
right and then i was like well if i'm
going to go to europe in the winter i
don't want to be miserable the whole
time i'm there so i started looking for
how do people train for cold and i saw
wim hof which is a dude who [ __ ]
climbed mount everest or whatever in
shorts yeah oh my [ __ ] god he's never
wearing a shirt yeah he's like swimming
in ice
i mean but the elements bro like you're
[ __ ] a huge like humans are weak as
[ __ ] right and he's doing it in a show
the modern human but the modern human
right like before how did we do it we
were hunting wooly mammoths yeah
yeah we don't have north faces barefoot
come on not in the snow we [ __ ]
hunted and we used the [ __ ] skin of
animals we didn't have gore-tex
no we had bears sandals we had [ __ ]
beaver beaver shoes yeah that shit's
[ __ ] that's hot how much do how much
is for real for cause it's expensive
dude because it's good yeah it's not as
warm as patagonia yeah
yeah but their bodies were slowly
developed from childhood to deal with it
like yeah there are even stories of like
um
you know british explorers going to
polynesia and then they wrote how the
polynesian people had like extra layers
of skin like it looked really thick
because they're naked so they're exposed
to the elements and then you're you just
build thicker skin literally are your
feet still hella rough
they're smooth but i think they've
built like callous i guess have you seen
his [ __ ] feet is it worse this guy
could tear carpet right now if he wanted
to
i could use my heel like if it itched
here it's rough enough where i could use
my heel and scratch it and it feels like
i have nails it's gnarly man but i'm
proud of it and then if i actually feel
bad if i lose it like if i'm walking
around and i'm like oh it's all tender i
actually feel bad like i feel like i
earned it and now like shoes are an
option
and it feels like my character leveled
up in a game where i can now be like in
gravel mode or something and there's
research now saying like how shoes
actually contribute to like leg problems
when you're old you know when you're
like old and then like
they're saying like you got bad knees
and ankles and all that it's because
like you know humans were meant to just
walk barefoot
so
i don't know yeah
all right well
damn we're kind of coming to like
closing thoughts here are there any
questions you want to ask great because
i gotta pee but let's go no
nothing really no um any anything that
you wanna i mean i'm so fascinated by
the way you think and and i love that
the way you think i don't know if i've
ever told you but like your brain is so
inspiring because you could just give a
[ __ ] less
like you can give a [ __ ] less and i
absolutely love that because like
i'll see you like go to the gym and
you're the only dude at a power lifting
gym in the corner on our turf just
[ __ ] doing martial arts not giving
karate [ __ ]
where most people would be like
okay wait no like this like i'm not i'm
not like vibing with the rest of the
space here you know but you're just like
[ __ ] it i don't care like where does
this come from like was there like a
moment that you were like aha or you've
just always been
free i'm probably like embarrassed after
i did it because i remember i was
dancing at barbell and i was like oh my
god the mirror is so good for dancing
and so in between my lips i would go and
then i would just do the waves and [ __ ]
and i'm like dude i wish i had big-ass
mirrors like this and i saw this guy
like laughing at me and i was like oh
[ __ ]
damn this isn't appropriate right now so
you don't even control it it just
happens
kind of it's it's yeah i think that's
what i mean by like i just do it because
i want to do it and then later i'm just
like thinking about it like oh that was
kind of embarrassing like
maybe i shouldn't have done that you
know and then i'm like man that guy made
fun of me and i'm like oh well i did it
though
i think that's a better way to live
though i think at least you pursue what
is
the most honest you right like you have
an honest feeling you pursue that
feeling
versus i think a lot of people have of
honest feeling but they have so many of
their it's me personal people going no
no no no like their own internal parent
and then they don't do it and then it
gets it has to get let out you know and
i still have the no no no in me it's
just probably not the same i don't
believe it yeah i don't think it's the
same as most people but i do have it
where i'm like oh that's that doesn't
look safe i shouldn't do that or
whatever
yeah i think it's just the the levels
different from people yeah my no no no
it's mainly her i think
yeah it is it probably really is i was
telling joe in the garage we were going
to check up the snow and then there's
like a big pile of snow and then like
everyone's pulling over to park to play
because that's where the kids play with
the snow sleds on the side and she goes
i don't think you should park here i'm
gonna [ __ ] it
when i got stuck and my [ __ ] tires
are spinning and just snow splattering
everywhere she goes i told you it felt
so good it [ __ ] felt so good to be
like aha i called it and tekken are all
playing in the snow having a good ass
time he's trying to take his truck out
that's so funny but what's tight is the
guy that pulled me out and uh he was
like um
i was like oh man my wife told me not
even not to even pull over anyways he
goes what are you going to do we're
dudes
that's true we were scientists yeah yeah
and then she was like see are you did
that teach you a lesson now you got to
listen to me i'm like no because you're
not going to do it again no now it tells
me oh i should have had a winch
that's that's well was the missing part
yeah wind should have been really tight
yeah this is the second time your ass
gets stuck third time that you get stuck
and you can't get out yeah pull myself
out so i need to get a winch now yeah
the the second time the first time was
when we were dating he's in trying to
impress me
um but then we weren't even dating that
truck didn't have four wheel drive
though fine that was the first time
second time uh was we were at a barbell
retreat
he drove into the big bear lake when
it's you know when it gets dry
he drove into that [ __ ] does it look dry
at the top oh i remember yeah you guys
were stuck for like six hours lifted
black truck like it's well how big is
that lift
maybe like three inches at 33 inches
tires it's pretty big yeah and when you
open the door the [ __ ] ground was at
like you're level at the door
i'm like this [ __ ]
and right when i get in the lake bed and
went
and then my tires
got stuck and you know tow truck and a
tow truck had to pull out yeah
i talk a bunch of [ __ ] but like it's fun
memories like for sure fun memories but
it just feels so good to be right it's
better than having a peaceful trip
yeah yeah i guess so you want to flip
your car and do some crazy [ __ ] and then
you're like that was kind of cool yeah
that's true that's true i just don't
like the inconvenience after that i have
a thought yeah so
i think
okay i think i actually do
give a lot of [ __ ]
but
it depends on what it is so like maybe
i'm just finding this out right now but
i think the the thing is what people
value and care about
is not the same thing that i care about
so what's important to me let's say like
is achieving
practice time at the gym and that's the
only time i have to do it so am i going
to sacrifice
that or just put up with the shame and
and practice dancing at a powerlifting
gym or whatever right and then so at the
because the end goal is being able to
achieve being a better dancer so i if i
have the place and time to do it right
now i don't want their opinions and
their
these strangers
thoughts to bother me yeah so then like
especially if they're strangers right
and then i think that's the thing is
that if i'm not bothering them being
rude um if i'm not really
messing things up it's just it's just
judgment yeah that's all it is and to me
i don't care about
that it's like if the judgment doesn't
hurt me in any way it doesn't hurt my
business doesn't
it it really just doesn't matter it's an
opinion and i think that um that's where
i don't give a [ __ ] because i think
what's more important what i do give a
[ __ ] is achieving the things that i want
sick
yeah no i that makes 100 sense for sure
and that's um something it's funny
because i see a lot of that in my mom i
[ __ ] adore my mom i love my mom she's
the [ __ ] best mom ever but i mean she
just grew up in a time where everyone's
judging right yeah so i grew up from her
her mindset of like everyone's looking
at me like we got to present ourselves
like in the best light ever you don't
want to speak this way you don't want to
sit this way you want to behave this way
because what are they going to think but
you know no one's looking at you
absolutely everyone's thinking about
themselves absolutely and i know this
right because i'm like when i hear her
like if i'm like hey mom let's go get
food she goes oh i'm not dressed like uh
appropriately or whatever and i'm like
you're not that important yeah no one's
even gonna know that you walked into the
room like you're not gonna affect
anyone's life your mom needs to steal
more yeah
because you know because you know when
you're stealing you're like oh my god
everyone's looking at me oh my god right
yeah but if you've actually stole a lot
yeah you don't do that literally
yeah
put it in your pocket and no one's
paying it because everyone's in their
own [ __ ] yeah i think that's the biggest
realization for me is everyone's so
[ __ ] focused on themselves yeah that
they don't give a [ __ ] about you and
maybe once in a while you have a mean
person that's just like judging you all
day but then at the end of the day their
opinions don't help you progress at life
make you better so why should you hold
yourself back
and then please them or please the
people just for a moment while you hold
yourself back from achieving the things
that you want i think that's the thing
that's like blows my mind that's so dope
well damn i don't even want to add to
that because it was such a profound
statement and it's such a dope
realization that you just kind of had
here why are you still talking then
because i'm about to close it out
please i gotta pee so bad okay so
joe has to has to pee but um i would
love to have you back this was such a
dope podcast it was so dope catching up
with you i [ __ ] love you and i'm so
happy to have you in my life man and i
know that you miss and you love the [ __ ]
out of me but it's just something hard
for you to say so i'll say it for you
geo as joe say it for you as joey i'll
move my lips
for me
as joe your friend i want to say three
things i think you're so beautiful i
think you're so smart
wait hey
i think you're so smart and i've missed
you so much
all right and on that note i want to say
thank you so much and we'll catch you
next week
bye bye